[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo ambroselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy abordamos la guerra en Ucrania un
año después de que empezara la invasión
Cómo ha cambiado el conflicto a la Unión
Europea ha sido su respuesta adecuada
para debatirlo hablamos con los
eurodiputados a Javi López del grupo
socialdemócrata bienvenido Javi Muchas
gracias
y a José Ramón bauza del grupo renovar
Europa bienvenido José Ramón un placer
como siempre
ha pasado Ya un año desde que empezara
la guerra y ya se está hablando en los
últimos días en las últimas semanas que
este conflicto estamos viendo que se
está alargando Pero existe el que el
conflicto se eternice que se congele
podría pasar una situación parecida por
ejemplo a lo que ocurre en la península
Corea Javi sos uno de los riesgos que
hay que se cronifique el conflicto y por
eso es tan importante la asistencia
militar que hoy está otorgando la Unión
Europea a Ucrania para poder desbloquear
el conflicto y para que pueda recuperar
su soberanía todos en Europa buscamos la
paz pero una paz justa Que respete el
derecho internacional y los principios
que han Regido la convivencia en Europa
desde la desde el final de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial que es que no podemos
dibujar de nuevo fronteras mediante la
fuerza y eso es lo que hoy está en juego
entre Ucrania y Rusia y por eso es tan
importante que los principios europeos
se vean atacados y haya una respuesta
contundente por parte de la Unión
Europea José Ramón Bueno hay dos puntos
básicos en primer lugar hay un
territorio invadido que es Ucrania que
tiene todo su derecho legítimo a
recuperar la integridad territorial y
hay otro que es El Invasor que es en
este caso el que ha usurpado y ha
incumplido todos los derechos más
básicos tanto en este caso el artículo
51 de la carta de Naciones Unidas da ese
derecho a la legítima defensa a Ucrania
punto 1 segundo punto se cronificará o
se acabará tan rápido como más ayuda
seamos capaces desde las instituciones
europeas desde los países miembros desde
los aliados a facilitarles esas armas
ese material logístico En definitiva a
estar como mínimo en las mismas
condiciones bélicas que tienen este caso
Rusia por lo tanto será mucho más rápido
será mucho más corto en el tiempo Cuanto
más ayuda y más cerca en este caso
estemos de Ucrania de zelensky y de todo
su pueblo hablando de integridad
territorial en 2014 siempre dio primero
a la Península de de crimea luego empezó
la guerra en el donbash es posible
recuperar estos territorios Javi debe
ser posible para Ucrania poder respetar
su integridad territorial y su soberanía
no como bien Se ha explicado desde la
Segunda Guerra Mundial hemos construido
un mundo donde la convivencia entre
Estados independientemente de su fuerza
y de su tamaño fuera Total no de la
convivencia en base a el respeto a su
soberanía y su igualdad de condiciones
en el seno de la concertación de
Naciones que es Naciones Unidas eso es
lo que Rusia ha estado violentando
durante las últimas dos décadas no solo
en el caso de Ucrania hemos visto otros
casos como Georgia y es muy relevante
que ahora que se ocurren suelo europeo y
Ucrania está decidiendo defenderse
legítimamente ante un inversor reciba
por parte de la Unión Europea y por
occidente todo el apoyo necesario para
esa legítima defensa y además porque no
es solo algo que atañe a Ucrania no
estamos hablando del dombas o de crimea
Esa no es la discusión la discusión es
la arquitectura de seguridad europea que
se ha visto rota después de esta
invasión y que para Europa es tan
relevantes Así que lo que se discute
allí ese territorio que se discute en
Ucrania tiene que ver con la paz en el
resto de Europa
José Ramón no pregunta ya tenemos 10
paquetes de sanciones aprobados
Pero por otra parte el fondo monetario
internacional prevé un crecimiento para
Rusia puede ser que las sanciones no
hayan funcionado tanto como lo que
esperaba la Unión Europea Las Naciones
están funcionando lo que pasa es que hay
quienes pensaban también porque esa
situación nos había producido nunca que
el efecto de las sanciones era inmediato
en el tiempo es decir necesita un tiempo
para que sean efectivas y eso ya se
están notando estamos viendo Cómo se
produce una reducción desde un punto
global Aunque quisiéramos que fuera
menor estamos viendo por ejemplo en el
tema del gas ruso pero también se puede
ver el caso del pib y otras acciones
otros otros digamos otros otras
indicadores que no se tienen en tanto en
cuenta visiblemente como es el índice de
producción industrial o en la producción
de vehículos en definitiva las sanciones
son efectivas lo que pasa es que no son
tan definitorias en el corto plazo y lo
que no podemos dejar de hacer es
precisamente sancionar las sanciones no
solamente son económicas sino que
también son institucionales porque se
les pone directamente una marca una cruz
a aquellos que se consideran no
solamente como Quienes son los inmadores
y Los Invasores de un territorio en este
caso Ucrania sino los que están
rompiendo por completo lo que aquí
llamamos el loft lo que es el derecho
internacional pero sobre todo el derecho
a lo más básico y justo que existe en el
mundo que es simplemente el derecho a la
vida que es lo que se está produciendo
en este caso porque estamos hablando de
conflictos no lo que se está produciendo
es una guerra donde Hay muertos y
víctimas como consecuencia de que no un
pueblo invade sino un dictador y sus
secuaces son los que han tomado esas
decisiones por lo tanto las sanciones
Nos gustaría a todos que fuesen más
rápidas pero no pueden serlo más y por
eso con esa contundencia la última se
aprobó este fin de semana en la Unión
Europea está haciendo contundente mucho
más incluso que abortos territorios y
otras regiones del mundo
Javi eres presidente de la asamblea
eurolat y me gustaría preguntarte los
gobiernos de Brasil o de Argentina se
han negado a proveer de armas a Ucrania
para no abordado la posibilidad de crear
como una coalición de países para ser
mediadores ante el conflicto qué piensas
de este tipo de iniciativas primero en
Brasil y Argentina ambos son países del
g20 que además forman parte de esos
países que Naciones Unidas han decidido
apoyar las resoluciones propuestas y
promovidas por Ucrania de denuncia
de la violación que significa para el
derecho internacional la invasión o sea
son primer lugar segundo lugar sobre las
sanciones verdad que especialmente en
América Latina debido a su cultura
anti sanciones y antiinjerencistas no
han estado promoviendo y apoyando a las
decisiones alrededor de las sanciones Yo
respeto todo se ve desde desde
diferentes puntos de vista pero
cualquier iniciativa debería basarse en
que no estamos ante un conflicto
simétrico existe un agresor y un
agredido existe un Invasor y un invadido
y cualquier propuesta de paz tiene que
basarse en respetar ese Marco no básico
no en entender quién está siendo
agredido en la guerra y quién es el
agresor todas las propuestas de buena
voluntad son bienvenidas pero es
importante recordar que la lógica de dos
no se pelean si uno no quiere no
funciona cuando hay un país que intenta
defenderse legítimamente porque le están
invadiendo
recientemente se ha publicado un informe
en que se ven estas diferencias a las
que hacía mención Javi entre occidente y
el sur global no
puede ser el conflicto en Ucrania un
poco que marca aún más las diferencias
entre dos mundos al final distintos
sobre cómo se está encarando el
conflicto sí sin duda y además sabemos
las consecuencias cuando no se encarga
de esta forma hay una serie de países
que los que ha comentado en su global
que tienen una estructura geopolítica de
una visión idiosincrasia especial y que
quieren mantener sus propias
estabilidades quieren llevarse bien con
Rusia quieren llevarse bien con china
quieren comerciar y llevarse bien con
Europa y eso está muy bien sobre la mesa
pero hay que saber que en determinadas
ocasiones determinadas acciones generan
determinadas reacciones por lo tanto
dentro de esos países del está África es
sumamente importante tener en cuenta
geopolíticamente la situación en África
La retirada de muchos países miembro de
la geopolítica de África ha dejado
huecos que inmediatamente han sido
ocupados en este caso por Rusia y cuando
se habla de Rusia se tiene que hablar de
china porque en definitivamente es lo
mismo son países comunistas donde en
este caso china se está aprovechando del
periodo de guerra porque está haciendo
una auténtica sustracción de un bajo
coste de los de los de la riqueza y de
los productos de los cuales se nutre
china aparte de Rusia por eso sumamente
importante tener en cuenta esa situación
geopolítica hueco que tú dejas lo
incorpora otro y además la situación con
África es sumamente importante en el
corto y medio plazo situación económica
situación de población el incremento
poblacional de África es el más elevado
quitando a China y a la India el más
elevado del mundo con lo cual esa región
está creciendo Y también las injerencias
que se producen en este caso por países
comunistas van a van a generar políticas
totalmente diferentes a la que se están
por ejemplo produciendo y motivando
desde la Unión Europea por lo tanto hay
que tener mucho en cuenta que esos
países que yo entiendo o puedo entender
y obviamente no comparto que quieran
llevarse bien con todo el mundo a pesar
de la situación de crisis o de conflicto
bélico Tiene un gran efecto en este caso
porque estamos alimentando directamente
a Rusia y Rusia es una amenaza Rusia
china Irán En definitiva son las
amenazas mundiales
Javi hemos visto que donde ha habido
algún tipo de avances en el conflicto
sino en el plano humanitario lo hemos
visto con el acuerdo del grano en
Turquía puede ser igual si hay avances
en el plano humanitario avanzar igual
hacia la paz en la parte militar es
posible
las acuerdos que se han llegado se han
llegado especialmente para el grano No
para el traslado de grano por parte de
Ucrania básicamente Rusia Había decidido
bloquear las salidas de los puertos de
Ucrania de grano que abastecía buena
parte de África y del sur global que han
sido acuerdos básicamente auspiciados
por Naciones Unidas son bienvenidos
cualquier tipo de acuerdo de este tipo
es bienvenido y obviamente en último
término habrá algún tipo de negociación
eso evidentemente se sabe también en el
seno de la Unión Europea pero la
asistencia militar es necesaria y
condición para que un día haya una
negociación Hay a veces que se plantea
esto entre una disyuntiva entre la
disyuntiva dos alternativas o diplomacia
o ayuda militar y no yo creo es un falso
dilema me parece evidente que si no
hubiera habido asistencia militar hoy
Ucrania no existiría en el mapa no
habría diplomacia que hacer ni
negociación que hacer de hecho la
asistencia militar es la condición para
que un día pueda haber algún tipo de
negociación con desde el respeto
evidentemente a la soberanía y la
integridad territorial de Ucrania eso es
lo que se tiene que entender nosotros no
estamos decidiendo entre armas o
diplomáticos estamos básicamente hoy
haciendo asistencia militar para que un
día pueda haber esta negociación que
será necesaria seguramente en algunos
términos por eso es muy relevante los
esfuerzos que se hagan en cualquier
campo no por eso es importante que
Naciones Unidas mantenga las posiciones
que ha mantenido que en el seno de una
asamblea de Naciones Unidas la semana
pasada se haya vuelto a hacer una
denuncia por parte de la comunidad
internacional de forma muy muy
mayoritaria para que luego también entre
espacio a la negociación gracias a Javi
José Ramón Lamentablemente nos hemos
quedado sin tiempo pero muchas gracias
por vuestras aportaciones a ustedes les
esperamos en el próximo programa de
Europa hoy Gracias por ver France 24 en
español